non mais j'arrive sur un plateau
depuis combien de temps on est en train
de parler de alors nous parlons on est
avec Mireille de la rentrée Nathan
on est avec Mireille Dumas on fait une
consultation
j'accepterai pas je vous pose des
questions vous avez mon nom vous avez
mon adresse
brusquement le chirurgien sort une arme
d'autodéfense et nous met en jour
c'est bon
il vient de tirer au visage de notre
journaliste un projectile de liquide
lacrymogène
[Rires]
[Musique]
allez c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
c'est bon arrêtez arrêtez on s'en va ça
va [__] arrêtez arrêtez arrêtez
arrêtez vous avez pas le droit de faire
ça
hors de contrôle il réouvre la portière
de la voiture pour vider son chargeur
sur nous
poser des questions
nous partons et nous nous arrêtons un
peu plus loin pour évaluer les dégâts
notre journaliste est couvert de liquide
lacrymogène qui commence à produire ses
effets
ça va ça fait hyper mal outre le fait
que Radio télévision ou presse on peut
évoqués la violence des militants
d'ultra gauche qui ont tenté d'interdire
la séance de dédicace organisait dans un
hôtel de la ville le traitement la façon
dont les journalistes ont rapporté cet
événement mon sidéré au secours le
conducteur ce film avec son téléphone en
se faisant passer pour une victime
la glace elle casse ma voiture et ses
haltères sont le fait de gens qui
n'avaient rien à faire à cette réunion
violence illégale violence gratuite
violence politique je dirais évidemment
la même chose s'il était arrivé parmi
mésaventures à Philippe Poutou Jean-Luc
Mélenchon Nathalie Arthaud Fabien
Roussel tous scandidat en 2002 à
l'élection présidentielle je dirais la
même chose mais il y aura une différence
je ne serai pas le seul
au secours la police m'agresse
[Musique]
passée on agresseur
au secours au secours
le dénouement n'a pas été aussi
triomphant qui le souhaitait alors que
de coureurs de la même équipe
s'apprêtait à célébrer leur victoire
bras de ses bras dessous elle leur a
filé juste sous le nez un troisième
cycliste a surgé de nulle part une
impressionnante remontada qu'il n'avait
sûrement pas vu venir à en voir leur
réaction à quelques mètres seulement de
l'arrivée de ce Grand Prix en Auvergne
pris de consolation les deux ont tout de
même été sacré champion sur Twitter par
la Fédération de la loose on est sur
une cuisson
[Applaudissements]
il se donnait du plaisir dans le Nil et
c'est une
non il fertilisait ainsi le fleuve de sa
semence
divinement même si ça vient du Flow
est positif
sur tout ce que vous voulez prise de
sang alors déjà on va déjà aller au
commissariat monsieur
là vous foutez de ma gueule en fait
absolument pas monsieur on va appeler la
vraie police
[Musique]
j'en suis pas sûr ah bon alors là
c'est pas la France
[Musique]
la corona c'est vrai Géraldine oui une
bière ça va voilà une bière ça va de
bière bonjour les dégâts
voilà voilà
juste voilà il y a pas sa femme et dès
qu'il y a pas sa famille il fait
n'importe quoi il en Afrique il va
tripoter des mecs en boîte de nuit en
buvant des bières là il est dans le
vestiaire il regarde derrière le truc il
boit des bières il fait n'importe quoi
en fait tu vois dès qu'il est sans sa
femme il fait n'importe quoi je pense
que Macron doit pas le lâcher d'une
semaine tripoter les mecs tu as vu il
était comme ça sur le président
quand même l'image du jour c'est ce
couple de Corona qui tente de se
reconstruire après avoir été agressé par
Emmanuel Macron je l'ai chiné sur un
vide-grenier 6h du matin avec ma lampe
et avec ma femme alors est-ce qu'il y a
de la chance heureusement qu'on nous a
mis de la moquette
des rafales de vent soufflanta 100 km/h
sur cette route près de Château Rouge
dans la
un bruit impressionnant dans ce
restaurant situé sur un axe entre
Bourges et Tours les propriétaires
restent prudemment à l'intérieur on a
compté hier plus de 28 000 impacts de
foudre partout en France et notamment au
sommet de la Tour Eiffel regardez cette
incroyable photo qui a été prise par un
photographe qui a déjà fait le tour du
monde photos absolument
stupéfiante ici nous sommes bien dans
les toilettes des filles mais aussi des
garçons des sanitaires mixtes donc une
première pour le collège Albert Camus de
Rosny-sous-Bois fraîchement rénové une
nouveauté à laquelle les élèves se sont
progressivement adaptés j'ai commencé à
me familiariser avant j'avais peur vu
que je trouvais ça hyper bizarre les
garçons ils vont respecter les toilettes
ainsi que les filles par exemple nous
quand on a nos règles etc ils sont pas
dégoûtés enfin ils comprennent c'est
bien donc il a fait ses petites affaires
dans une cabine de plage
et ça pose problème j'y arrive parce
qu'en fait il avait une drôle d'habitude
il aime brûler son caca c'est sûr
et de qu'est-ce qu'il a fait il a brûlé
donc ses excréments et le problème c'est
que ça a pris feu la cabane à friture et
il a brûlé 250 m² de zone protégée une
charte écrite par les collégiens a même
été affiché à l'entrée de ses toilettes
avec le rappel de notion de propreté et
de respect les images qui vont suivre ne
sont pas extraites du film Les Dents de
la mer elles ont été prises à Alicante
en Espagne ou un requin bleu de 2 mètres
environ à semer la terreur chez les
baigneurs qui barbotaient au bord de
l'eau l'animal qui précise le est
inoffensif pour l'homme n'a lui pas
sembler paniqué par les mouvements de
foule ah Jésus a prêché le concert c'est
déjà sa troisième fois qui vient au l et
il est content de Jésus c'est un super
festival voilà on se bat on se marre
bien et tout